I want to show you two video clips one
of them is real and one of them is fake
can you tell which one's real
okay this one was kind of easy obviously
this is the fake one like you can see
the color on the face isn't quite right
and hair is obviously like a wig
but this video was like from a few years
ago let's look at a more recent example
look at these two clips one of them is
real and one of them is fake can you
tell which one it is
oh
okay what about these
or these which one of these is fake and
which one of these is real
maybe you're some Wizard and you could
tell but I couldn't and my guess is that
most people can't that's because things
have changed I've never seen it quite
like this this technology is spreading
rapidly it's really mind-blowing
spikes
in the last few years we've crossed a
threshold into a world where moving
images are manipulated in ways that make
them indistinguishable from reality this
is our new world it is the world of high
quality deep fakes the catastrophic
potential to public trust and to markets
that could come from Deep fake attacks
this is happening quicker than any of us
could have imagined so I want to get you
up to speed on what's happening with
deep fakes how their revolutionizing
entertainment
and creating new challenges and fears
for the people who make our laws and the
people who enforce those laws make it
look like anyone is saying anything at
any point in time ultimately I want to
show you how much of a threat deep fakes
actually pose and answer the biggest
question of all
what is even real
seeing is not believing anymore
okay it's actually me this is the real
Johnny I promise this is not a defect I
promise I'm not like gonna do like some
little bait and switch
I need to tell you about the sponsor of
today's video which is a thing I'm
really excited about I'm genuinely
excited not just because they're
supporting the channel but because I'm
actually excited four years now I have
been in a war with marketing people
secretive shadowy marketing people who
collect all of my data put it on lists
lots of lists and then sell it to
corporations who then flood my inbox and
my phone and my life with Spam lots of
spam this ends up creating a lot of
noise in my life a lot of noise that I
don't want and it has been impossible
for me to actually get myself off these
lists until incogni came around what
many of us don't know is that we
actually have legal protections against
our data being bought and sold and these
predatory marketing practices coming to
bear on us all of the time but it is a
very complicated and time-intensive
process to actually Implement those
rights with incogni you can get your
name off of these lists the creepiest
part about the this whole industry is
that there are people search websites
now where random people can just look
you up and learn a bunch of stuff about
you and cogney targets those as well
it's so satisfying because they show you
a dashboard of all of like the marketing
lists that they are working on to take
your name off of so you get to see your
name being taken off of all these lists
that you didn't even know you were on so
I'm signed up for the yearly plan which
means incognate is constantly monitoring
month after month to keep me off these
lists and I'm already seeing the results
I'm very very happy that incognit exists
which is why I'm so giddy right now
there's a link in my description it's
incogni.com Johnny Harris clicking that
link helps support the channel it also
gets you in on this amazing service you
can sign up and have 30 days risk free
where you can get all your money back if
you feel like it's not useful to you 30
days use the link go sign up thank you
Incognito for sponsoring today's video
let's dive back into the wild weird
world of deep fakes okay let's just be
clear we've been faking the moving image
for at least 100 years
Thomas Edison wanted to spice up his
news reporting from the front lines of
the Spanish-American War back in like
the end of the 1800s so to do this he
shot some fake battle scenes in New
Jersey and then cut them together with
shots from Cuba making this look like it
was happening in Cuba and it wasn't and
for the next hundred years Motion
Picture manipulation remained as crude
and simplistic as Edison's sneaky
editing but then suddenly in 2014 with
the invention of a new type of AI
everything started to change
incredibly realistic so-called deep
Faith how similar it is is there a way
to know when this is fake and to tell
when it's fake we now have the ability
to make people look like other people
like I could be Johnny or I could be
Nick the studio manager look I'm Nick
the studio manager right now I could
also be Tom the music composer and
what's crazy is even if you go back and
watch what I just showed you frame by
frame you likely won't be able to tell
let me explain how on Earth we did this
we can do all of this because of this
clever Computing process it's called
generative adversarial networks or Gans
this is where two AIS work in tandem to
get the best fake image possible so you
have these two AIS one of them is a
forger and the other is a detective the
forger creates an image based on what
you ask it to make and then it shows
that image to the other AI the detective
the detective goes over the image and
points out all of the reasons it's fake
it knows what to look for because it's
been trained on sometimes thousands of
images of exactly what the finished
products are supposed to look like the
forger is like okay cool let me try
again and it goes away and it makes
another image fixing the pixels that the
detective AI pointed out then it shows
it to the detective the detective AI
once again points out all of the
weaknesses in the fake image and the
forger goes back and makes a new one and
over and over and over again
and so the longer you give one of these
AI models to train on it basically goes
through this creation and Improvement
cycle over and over until you get the
best deep fake possible there are many
ways to train a deep fake but this is
the most common and it's actually how we
got the Deep fake that we're running on
this clip right now my face is slowly
morphing into something else and it's
basically Pixel Perfect we had to run a
training model on this face for two
weeks
but it got really good look it's like
amazing
I'm not me I mean I am me but I'm not
mean to you and that's kind of nuts it
scares me it really does it scares me an
important Point here is that we used to
have to train these models on huge
amounts of data you need a lot of
footage from someone's face to train
these models which is why it's mostly
worked on like actors who have a lot of
high quality face data available it's
how you get deep fakes like this you
like what you're seeing
or how you get Jim Carrey imposed onto
Jack Nicholson's face in the shiny I'm
just gonna hurt you or Willem Dafoe in
Silence of the Lambs instead of Anthony
Hopkins
these last two clips were done by a
super talented deep fake artist named
control shift face and he's actually the
one who's doing the Deep fakes for this
video too he's the artist behind that
video that went super viral a few years
ago of Bill Hader doing an Arnold
Schwarzenegger impression and turning
into Arnold Schwarzenegger
and he's now working at a deep fake
production company called Deep Voodoo
where he worked on that Kendrick Lamar
video
yes that Kendrick Lamar video for me
personally it's exciting because I can
like do this uh goofy funny movie
remixes that I can put on YouTube I
really enjoy that and yes when I was
talking to him in our interview he was
using a live deep fake mask and changing
between different characters and it kind
of blew my mind oh my God sorry you just
changed you just changed to Mark
Zuckerberg
here
wow I didn't know I was not ready for
that deep faking has already started to
shape the entertainment industry
makers are using deep fake technology to
translate films into other languages
it's all my fault
they can D age celebrities
and we're back there's a six-part TV
show in the UK about a bunch of Rowdy
neighbors and guess what all of these
characters are all deep faked
celebrities sorry
about two years ago if someone told me
something like this would exist I don't
think I would believe him and what will
be next in like another two three five
years it's getting to the point where
deep fakes are nearly impossible to
decipher as computer generated which is
super exciting but also kind of scary
the FBI tells NBC News they're following
the rapidly developing technology
closely I believe that this is the next
wave of attacks against America it's a
real concern it's a real concern
thank you and this is where we talk
about the Doom and Gloom part and for
that yes I have a lot of paper
[Music]
lawmakers and law enforcement are
getting worried about this technology
here's a letter from Congress to the
Director of National Intelligence
raising the alarm that hyper realistic
digital forgeries popularly referred to
as deep fakes use sophisticated machine
learning techniques to produce
convincing depictions of individuals
doing or saying things that they never
did I kind of love when Congress talks
about technology and this is the most
important line by blurring the line
between fact and fiction deep fake
technology could undermine public trust
in recorded images and video as
objective depictions of reality oh and
by the way this letter was back in 2018
basically the Stone Age for AI image
generation more recently I saw
Democratic senator giving his opening
remarks to his colleagues in Congress
via a deep faked voice that sounded
perfectly like him we have seen what
happens when technology outpaces
regulation but it's not just American
lawmakers yeah
europol which is the European
International police agency says that
experts estimate that as much as 90
percent of online content may be
synthetically generated by 2026. 90
meaning AI will be making most of the
stuff that we watch on the internet
their big fear in all of this is that
deep fakes will quote lead to a
situation where citizens no longer have
a shared reality causing what they call
an information apocalypse here is a
43-page report from the U.S Department
of Homeland Security and look at this
title page I mean look at that graphic
design especially this moment where it
goes from a classic Sans serif to a
serif I mean not bad for the government
DHS says that deep fakes and the misuse
of synthetic content pose a clear
present and evolving threat to the
public across National Security Law
Enforcement financial and societal
domains the Pentagon is using its big
research wing the one that helped invent
I don't know the GPS the coveted vaccine
and the literal internet that one to
look into deep fakes and how to combat
them like they're taking this very
seriously but my big problem with all of
these reports is they're couched in such
vague language what can deep fakes
actually be used for outside of making
really cool Kendrick Lamar music videos
and Tick Tock Tom cruises
we'll forget a taste look no further
than Ukraine the Russian president says
a military operation is now underway in
eastern Ukraine column of Russian armor
Crossing into Ukrainian territory from
the north yeah
this is not Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski this is a deep faked video
that appeared on a Russian language
Ukrainian news site just four weeks
after Russia invaded Ukraine Russian
troops were trying to take over Kiev
which would have meant a massive victory
for Putin information on the ground was
scant and foggy and this video pops up a
Vladimir silinski urging his troops to
surrender to Russian forces now listen
this is kind of a crappy version of a
deep fake I mean misshapen head weird
accent and voice wasn't super pulled off
but guess what it doesn't matter because
what this video did do is it made people
question every other video coming out of
your Crane and this is what Congress
meant when they were freaking out in
2018 about the idea of deep fakes
blurring the line between fact and
fiction undermining trust in recorded
images and videos as objective
depictions of reality and this is
actually so far in my reporting on this
the biggest takeaway I don't know if we
realize what a big shift this is as deep
fake technology gets better yes it
allows people to create compelling fake
evidence and that is worrisome but it
also allows people to dismiss real
evidence real footage as oh that's just
a deep fake we can do that now we can't
trust anything uh it's not just what
they could create it's the doubt that is
cast on authentic video and audio Yeah
okay let's get to another concrete
threat here to get us away from all the
vague language of government agencies
talking about how scary this all is
think about the legal system
teamfix are becoming a nightmare for
evidence in court in 2020 there was a
child custody case where the mother
presented as evidence audio recording of
the child's father saying violent things
over the phone it was submitted as legit
evidence as proof to be like this Dad is
unfit to have the kid but after some
digital forensics it became clear that
the mother had used an online tutorial
and some cheap software to doctor the
audio file to add in fake violent words
most judges and juries are not ready for
this most wouldn't think to question
evidence like this that sounds like a
Smoking Gun and yet was totally fake
this sort of technology is getting so
accessible and easy to use in fact this
vo that you're listening to right now is
actually fake I made it using a cheap
and easy software widely available to
anyone now imagine that you're on a jury
and you're presiding over a criminal
case and even though there may not be
any manipulated evidence in front of you
there's now a nagging voice in the back
of your mind that's like remember that
time that Johnny tricked me in that
YouTube video and he made his face
change and now he looks like someone
else and it wasn't really him and it was
really convincing who's to say all of
this Visual Evidence that I'm seeing in
court isn't also fake Visual Evidence is
no longer Rock Solid surveillance
footage body cam footage heck even audio
taken in a bus from a presidential
candidate this was all solid at one
point and now it can all be called into
question
and then of course deep fakes are being
used for good old-fashioned cyber crime
man cyber crime it just sounds so quaint
cyber crime Elon Musk was recently faked
to help shill a new crypto scam next.net
a site that will help Ordinary People to
gain Financial Independence and yeah
this one's obviously fake and poorly
done my point is they're getting better
and some scams are already way more
persuasive like this group of fraudsters
who were able to clone the voice of a
major Bank director and then use it to
steal 35 million dollars in Cold Hard
Cash 35 million dollars
just by Deep faking this guy's voice and
like using it to make a phone call to
transfer a bunch of money and it worked
[Music]
okay but in reality the risk of eroding
trust in the public or weakening our
legal system or giving cyber criminals a
new weapon all of these are actually the
rarest uses of deep fakes the main
victims of this new technology at least
at the moment are women these
these suggestive ads are popping up
online sexual misuse of these defects
she's been deep faith
by one estimate 96 of deep fake
production is used to produce porn
almost all of which are using women who
have not consented to this just two
years ago telegram got in trouble
because it was found that they had
private groups on their service that
were using deep fake technology to
remove the clothes of more than a
hundred thousand women it used to just
be the faces of celebrities because
they're the ones who have all this high
quality data out in the world that you
can train a model on but no longer the
tech has developed such that an ordinary
person with a few images on social media
could suddenly have their faces deep
faked onto the body of a porn star
Martin has found dozens of doctored
images and videos of herself she has no
idea who's responsible for them
okay but what's being done about this
what can be done let's first remember
that when a new technology comes along
it typically evolves rapidly way faster
than the lawmakers who need to
understand it to regulate it do so we're
in the kind of wild west phase where the
lawmakers are kind of just trying to get
their head around this stuff let's hope
that Congress can catch up China is
actually the first country to have
regulated what they call Deep synthesis
Technologies by requiring all deep fake
content to be clearly marked as having
been modified luckily a surveillance
state is a lot easier to regulate this
kind of stuff but the EU is trying in an
ambitious build called the AIX boy do I
love going through European commission
PowerPoint slides
like China the EU is trying to make it
so that you have to label deep fakes but
of course in a western democracy you
have to put this line unless necessary
for the exercise of a fundamental right
or Freedom or for reasons of public
interest oh man those pesky rights
always getting in the way of being able
to regulate stuff the UK is also trying
to figure this out they are targeting
the porn situation the one that is the
mass majority of the uses of deep fakes
doing deep fake porn without consent
comes with a penalty of prison though
it's super hard to enforce this stuff
that's what's so tricky but they're
trying will the government take urgent
action and repair dismissed and then
there's tech companies like here on
YouTube they say that they will pull
down any video that quote includes
deceptive uses of manipulated media I.E
deep fakes which may pose serious risk
of harm who decides what serious risk of
harm is all right but one promising
solution here would be to fight software
with software if we could train software
to detect the quirks of deep fakes like
the unnatural blinking or some of the
other weird subtle things that the human
eye can't pick up on we would have a
strong way of verifying what is real
footage and what is distorted so deep
fakes are here and they're seemingly
here to stay we are entering a new
chapter of how humans consume and relate
to information it's a chapter as
significant in my mind as some of the
other big chapters like when we learned
to capture light and record it it
changed the world photographs could be
used in court as proof
they can be used in science to capture
and understand the world around us in
journalism it allowed us to show not
just tell
and when we made those images move we
could capture more truth more proof more
evidence and then we could connect and
spread those images far and wide truth
and evidence coursed through the world's
internet
this evolution of the moving image and
its uses in the connected world is
taking an unexpected turn away from
being the Bedrock of evidence and
towards the foggy territory of deception
and confusion we're gonna have to
navigate this chapter carefully
we're gonna have to push even harder to
know where our images came from who made
them and for what purpose and we're
going to have to resist the urge to
believe everything we see no matter how
real it looks
[Music]
laughs
foreign